with almost 500 sessions in next 2019
it's understandable you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see her
non-use of delivering choosing the right
GCE instance type for your workload then
stay tuned because here's the rewind
[Music]
working with the cloud provider to match
your unique needs with their specific
capabilities can be tricky it can be
almost impossible to find the right VM
at the right cost with the right
performance in the right locations and
that's not even taking into account that
your needs and budget will change as
your project grows there's got to be a
better solution which is why GCP from
day one focused on taking a different
approach see we believe in simplicity
flexibility and efficiency it should be
simple to decide what instance types use
for your workloads you should have the
flexibility to scale up or down or even
change your instances as needed and your
cloud offering should be efficient you
should not be paying for resources
you're not using at TCP we do this by
offering four types of VM specialize for
your specific workloads
we've got general-purpose computer mais
memory optimized and even preemptable
VMs so how do you actually pick the
right VM type for you on Google cloud
for 90 percent of your workloads you can
find exactly what you need with just one
click yes one click because for most of
your needs general-purpose VMs are the
most flexible and simplest option
they're great for a wide range of
workloads like gaming databases web
serving and more they let you upgrade
for more speed or storage create custom
machine types and you even get
recommendations that tell you when you
can make changes like downsizing to a
smaller VM that will save you money it's
pretty cool but what about applications
with more specialized CPU restores needs
if you need cutting-edge processing
power for intensive workloads
that's where compute optimized VMs come
into play these offer the highest
performance per core available on GCP
and are a great fit for triple-a gaming
high performance computing and some
types of scientific modeling because you
get full transparency to the underlying
Hardware tight consistency and
predictable performance so you can bet
your most intensive application on these
VMs so if you're making the next
fortnight this
might be for you now what about memory
intensive applications that deal with a
ton of data that's where memory
optimized VMs come into play they have a
lot of size from one terabyte to
approximately 12 terabytes with more
coming these are a great fit for things
like high end or in-memory databases
real time and in memory analytics these
use cutting edge technology to make it
simple for you to persist data scale up
or down your application and access data
at high speeds and that brings us to the
final type of workload bursty jobs where
you need to run thousands of cores for a
very short time on the cloud that's a
job for preemptable VMS are affordable
short-lived VMS that run for up to 24
hours and can be preempted at any point
in time these are great for fault
tolerant batch or rendering jobs or
simulations where you need compute
resources but you don't need the
application to run in real time what's
cool is this feature is really just a
flag that you can add to any other
previous VM types and once you add this
flag you automatically get a fixed 80%
discount so you get a predictable
pricing model to wrap up if you're
looking for simple efficient and
flexible VMs for your workloads whether
you're using a lot of CPU or memory
whether they're for batch workloads or
even something in-between Google compute
engine makes it easy to find the right
VM at the right cost with the right
performance for your needs if you'd like
to see pennons full talk which goes in a
much more detail about the technologies
that make each of these VM types
possible click on the link in the
description below and don't forget
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more next rewind content I'm Carter
Morgan thanks for watching
[Music]